[Ukraїner
Національні спільноти]
[Апостолове,
Подніпров'я та Запоріжжя]
Річ у тім, що Всеукраїнська асоціація корейців
щороку у різних містах України проводить
фестиваль корейської культури
Переважно проводимо у великих містах
[Олена Єгай
викладачка образотворчого мистецтва]
Це вперше проводимо у такому малому районномі центрі
Може це пов'язано із високою густотою населення етнічних корейців тут
Здавалося б, Південна і Північна Корея з іншого боку планети,
а ми чомусь проживаємо тут
В дитинстві це завжди було мені незрозумілим,
Це питання тоді якось не розглядали
І лиш нещодавно почали розповідати,
що корейців депортували з Далекого Сходу
та переселили до Середньої Азії
[співають корейською]
Морква-че, баклажани — «каді-хе» називаємо.
Морква-че,
[Світлана Хан,
мешканка Апостолового]
Огірки-че
Кімчі — квашена капуста
Олена Сергіївна зробила подарунок
Оце яблучний сік. Налити?
Так, так, ось Олена Сергіївна!
— Це моя чашка?
— Так, звісно, це твоя чашка.
Що мам?
— Ну як, хвилюєшся?
— Ні!
— Ти налаштувався на завтрашній виступ?
— Так.
— А я буду дивитися.
Бабуся тебе підтримувати буде,
перший раз на сцену з тобою вийде.
Дідусь увімкне прямий ефір,
і я буду вас бачити
Добре, мам.
Тому не хвилюйся, я побачу в прямому ефірі твій виступ
Перші корейці тут з'явилися, наскільки я знаю, під кінець 1960-х
Їздили сюди на роботу
А чому їздили:
бо там всі люди займаються землеробством,
в Ташкенті, маю на увазі
Тому там землі практично нема для нас.
А коли ми приїхали сюди, то побачили тут вдосталь землі,
і її можна обробляти
— ...то ж раніше колгоспи були
— Тому ми й переїхали сюди,
займатися землеробством. Ось і все.
Хоча ми й етнічні корейці,
[Ернест Кім,
мешканець Апостолового]
все одно, тут ми прожили вже понад 20 років
Якщо стільки часу ми проживаємо тут,
а там де проживаємо, я вважаю, це і є наша батьківщина
Поїхали якось в Корею і там про Україну все думали.
Все таке смачне було в Україні, а тут...
Не так, як ми переважно готуємо, не така їжа.
— Я й кажу: мені би борщуз картоплею,
— Там ми все своє готували
Там все добре.
Капіталістична країна, все чисто, все...
Але, як сказати, ми звикли  тут жити
У нас менталітет не такий, щоб там жити.
Південні корейці мене побачили: українець?
«Ви теж на нас схожі», —запитують
А я кажу: «Так, так!»
[сміються]
Ви йтимете туди, за вами винесуть барабани,
а ви двоє — сюди і за вами вже барабани
— Гаразд?
— Добре.
А з самого початку, що буде, до того як ми починаємо барабанити?
Виходять ведучі і кажуть: «Доброго дня, шановні глядачі!»
[намагається вимовити корейською]
Я щось не так сказала?
— А як?
— Аньо-хасейо!
А в нас написано не так, ось бачите!
«Аньо-хасейо!»
— Ні, не правильно?
— Та все гаразд
Отже дивіться.
Далі вони кажуть: «Ми раді вітати вас на фестивалі
Кореяда 2019»
Ми будемо поруч. А ви одразу виходите і показуєте свій номер.
Потім ви йдете зі сцени
— Гаразд. Після слів «Кореяда 2019»
— Найперші слова «Кореяда 2019»
Як вам зручніше: чи з того боку зручніше?
Та ні, давайте всі з одного боку.
Та ми ж не ставимо, переставимо
— «Кореяда 2019»
— Так
— ...а вони стоять зараз
Ми ж фільм переставили після танцю, ви ж сказали щойно!
«Кореяда 2019»
Я думаю, що барабани прийшли із  релігійних традицій
Їх використовували шамани,
також у буддистських храмах завжди є барабани
[Марина Лі,
керівниця ансамблю корейського танцю «Тораді»]
І ритми барабанів, до прикладу...
кажуть, що можуть зцілювати людину,
Коли, наприклад, людина хворіла, її ставили всередину,
навколо стояли барабани,
і ритми цих барабанів підіймали їй енергетику.
У нас спеціальні такі освітні програми, які проводило посольство:
ми їздили вивчати танці на острів Чіндо — це в Кореї.
До нас також приїздили волонтери, які нас вчили.
Я думаю, кожна людина має зберігати коріння.
Мистецтво — це те, що йде з глибин, з історії,
і, скажімо, якщо ми це підтримуємо,
якщо ми це демонструємо іншим людям,
то ми не даємо собі забути своє ж коріння.
У мене було таке, що мені казали, що я не така,
а я — дитина, я виросла в Україні, я цього не розумію:
як це я відрізняюсь?
Я — як всі: бігаю, одягаюсь та інше.
То було трохи важко.
[Олександра Тен,
учасниця ансамблю корейського танцю «Тораді»]
Але коли ти стаєш дорослішою,
то розумієш, що в тебе є два коріння,
і мені здається, що це більше збагачує людину.
Порівнювати, підтримувати традиції обох народів.
Це завжди краще, коли ти більше знаєш,
більше бачиш, більше розумієш.
Мабуть, я в Україні себе сприймаю більше українкою,
але коли спитають: «Хто ти за національністю?»,
я скажу, що я — кореянка, тому що зовнішність відрізняється,
а так — не знаю.
Три-чотири!
[співають корейською]
І ще раз наново.
— Це що? Ця тека теж туди їде?
— Так. Це взуття моє. Візьми, звісно.
Без цього взуття я не зможу.
Наталю, ти подивись.
Шкарпетки у мене в сумці.
Подивись, я вже їду.
Так-так. Давай. Нема коли.
— Добридень, красуню наша!
— А де діти?
— На репетиції десь.
— Діти там, у фоє.
— Ай, вона колеться.
— Ні, почекай.
— Ви уже виступали?
— Ні. Боляче, бабусю.
Корея — країна маленька.
Територія Південної Кореї у шість разів менша за Україну,
а проживає населення — 52 млн.
Тобто там землі практично немає.
[Ден Сік Кан
президент Асоціації корейців України]
І тому по всьому світові проживає ще приблизно 8 мільйонів корейців.
По всьому світові
Таких компактних проживань як "чайна таун" у всьому світі —
такого немає в нас.
Ми розкидані.
Більш-менш компактно проживають тут, в Апостоловому,
у Херсонській області, у Миколаївській області,
частково — в Одесі.
Коли Україна стала незалежною,
ми зібрались і вирішили, що необхідно віднайти всіх корейців.
Почали шукати всіх,
і створили в 1992 році Асоціацію корейців України.
У багатьох містах почали створюватись осередки.
З тих пір ми існуємо.
Мої батьки у 1942 році — ще при  японцях —
переїхали з Кореї на Сахалін,
південну частину Сахаліну, яка була тоді територією Японії.
Потім, після звільнення в 1945 році, вони там так і залишились,
не змогли поїхати до Південної Кореї — своєї батьківщини,
бо тоді не можна було поїхати.
І багато приїхали вчитись в Україну.
Я так само приїхав вчитися,
вступив до Київського політехнічного інституту, закінчив,
ну і з тих пір живу в Україні уже багато років.
Було таке відчуття, знаєте, що це благодатний край:
спокійно, просторо, гарна земля, хороші люди,
всього вистачає.
Цим і відрізнялась Україна від Росії, де я 17 років прожив
до того як приїхав сюди.
Там були конфлікти, ображали, усіляке було.
А тут спокійно. Дуже толерантно.
Тому корейці Україну дуже люблять.
[співають корейською]
[Корейська спільнота в Україні почала активно формуватися в другій половині ХХ ст.]
[і сьогодні налічує вже понад 30 тисяч осіб.]
[Здебільшого корейці мешкають у південних регіонах України]
[та намагаються відроджувати власну мову і традиційну культуру.]
[Переживши масове переселення владою Японії на острів Сахалін на початку ХХст.,]
[а згодом — депортацію радянською владою до країн Центральної Азії у 1937 році,]
[корейці з 1960-х років акттвно приїздили в Україну працювати на землі й оселялися тут.]
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Продюсерка
Оля Шор]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Оператори
Марія Теребус, Олександр Портян]
[Режисерка монтажу
Марія Теребус]
[Субтитрувальниці
Софія Анжелюк, Оля Стулій]
[Ukraїner
Національні спільноти]
[Серія відео створена за підтримки Агентства США з міжнародного розвитку (USAID)]